I made mistakes but mistakes make you
strong
hey guys so today is a very special
video because today with a first ever
unboxing video on D LM model lifestyle
so I'm super excited
we got sunglasses and they're from the
Scandinavian eyewear company called
Christopher Lewis some of you might know
them some of you might not I'm a very
big fan thank you guys so much for
sending this out to me if you guys don't
know what it looks like and if you're
curious let me show you all right well
first impressions the box man it looks
really good
very professional that's the first thing
that you can realize of products glasses
especially that is very high quality it
is not just what it looks like but the
boxing that it comes in
look at this Christopher Lewis Danish
our company playing simple looks classy
all right if you get a box and the name
is not on it then you have to consider
if it's a fake some of us anyway
let's have a look Wow look at that
that's pretty cool just feel like mmm
when you open this up right let's have a
look okay so this is the holder then you
get this thing as well it's pretty cool
[Music]
let's have a look so this is the first
one they sent me three sunglasses thank
you guys so much this is pretty cool I
do love this packaging so first
impressions yeah I like it they have a
lot of detail in it let's take these off
and see the Christopher Lewis right
there Wow
hand-finished it looks good the whole
thing screams quality I do like it a lot
so this shape is not gonna work hundred
percent for me because this shape is a
square shape if you're wondering what
kind of glasses were working with your
face shape then you have to think the
opposite of whatever is your face shape
so for example if you have a round face
then these sunglasses will work for you
for me any theaters or something that's
round because I have more a kind of a
rectangular square face to look
[Music]
all right yes
these guys mm-hmm got an aviator shape
so I love them immediately a v-shape
they just fits in with every kind of
face shape out there have a look oh my
goodness I think oh yes these are my
favorite so far
[Music]
yes I do like these ones they are pretty
cool very very very awesome sunglasses
alright next one the last one oh man you
guys you spoiled me from Christopher
clue as I love you guys already my
goodness oh this is kind of nice
this is around sunglasses are on shape
that's how the look oh yes
[Applause]
there you go my favorite is definitely
this guy espresso aviator shades
sunglasses
Christopher clothes you did a great job
every little detail in this thing is
good and these is it some bars by Robin
Thicke
you guys know the singer right he's the
guy who wears these losses pretty
awesome yes when you favorite my new
go-to glasses whoo
I thought of the links for you guys in a
video description so you can go and
check it out
guys if you liked the video give it a
thumbs up subscribe and I'll see you in
the next video
Cheers
[Music]
[Applause]
you